I know this is not going well I haven't  been on a date in 20 years I haven't  been on a date since senior year are you  married in college yeah me too really  yes the high-risk mission that train out  there is a national asset not Amtrak we  gonna go just about when the look of the  casings on those Minuteman ICBMs i'm  guessing the digital modules been  bypassed and you're preppin for full  analog retrofit is my jaw supposed to  drop I get it yo D wow you look amazing  and maybe a little uncomfortable I look  like Jane Austen threw up all over me  you do not look like Jane Austen there  no you look you look absolutely  beautiful you can breathe in that thing  right you guys what I don't do anything  I've been here all day just relax Peter  we're not cops no you're not cops hey  what's with this gift youngsters place  that's an old cult what a teleporter no  he says fast  is it true it is my ass said it was an  evil fairy I can't remember her name  they said it was Maleficent  you